[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 sport le magazine
consacré à l'actualité sportive dans le
département et tout de suite le sommaire
en val après quatre victoires en quatre
matches les mitaines trébuche en 5e
journée les leaders de nationale 2 se
sont inclinés ce week-end face aux roses
hand rugby une toute nouvelle équipe
l'union rugby centre fait un bon début
de saison les joueurs ont remporté une
troisième victoire ce week-end nous
ferons le point sur ses premiers mois de
compétition et en cyclisme 170 engagé
pour la première manche de la coupe
d'hiver ce dimanche 10 novembre le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille le sixième grand prix
de vélizy avant de faire le point sur
les principaux résultats un mot de voile
la transat jacques vabre continuer dans
la catégorie des imoca
louis burton est encore en cours sur son
bureau vallée parti le dimanche 27
octobre dernier du havre le skipper en
bout l'état en binôme et davy beaudart
pointe pour le moment à la 14e place du
classement
[Musique]
et on débute avec du handball c'est la
première défaite pour la saison pour les
aînés monteyne invaincu jusque-là les
leaders de nationale 2 ont échoué face à
aarau zand samedi soir lors de la 5e
journée
elle s'incline 17 à 22 retour sur le
match sur des images de marylène yapi
chine au match frustrant
invaincu depuis le début de la saison
les minimes antennes ont manqué de
réussite sur cette 5e journée
en première mi-temps les finistériennes
de rose on met la pression et mène
jusqu'à cinq points d'écart on
communique pas donc on les laissait
vraiment venir jouer jusqu'à 6 mètres
sur ce qui nous a fait défaut
les joueuses étaient un petit peu lourde
sur les jeux transition donc on attaque
on faisait pas ce qu'on soit la demande
et ter au départ résultats donc l'équipe
adverse a pris confiance et commencer à
nous faire mal sur le jeu de transition
les joueuses de brahim c'est à dire
viennent en seconde mi temps avec un
regain d'énergie et marquent quatre
points sans réponse des adversaires mais
elles ne prendront jamais davantage
on m'aurait ça prend un petit coup
mais en nettement on va vraiment
travaillé pour surpasser ça parce qu'on
n'a pas on a fait beaucoup pour rester
sur du positif
en fait c'est qu'on a fait beaucoup de
en attaque c'était pas ça mais en
défense je trouve qu'on était vraiment
là et c'est ce qui va surtout nous aider
à pas tomber moralement on va bien
récupérer ce week-end l'efficacité au
tiers sur tout et ne pas mélanger la
précipitation et la rapidité qui sont
deux éléments complètement différent
parce qu'on a à cause de la
précipitation on a perdu beaucoup de
ballons en attaque ce qui est fait que
bam façon qui s'enchaînent lésigny
monteyne s'incline 17 à 22 ans un accroc
en ce début de saison
mais elle ne compte pas baisser les bras
elle joue le samedi 9 novembre contre
issy paris
actuellement cinquième au classement du
côté du football et de trappes la saison
continue d'être compliqué pour l'étoile
sportive leurs équipes seniors de
régionale 2 s'est inclinée ce week-end
face à villemomble score 2 à 0 c'est la
cinquième défaite en six journées de
championnat l'équipe pointe pour le
moment à la 11e place de sa poule
l'information a été donnée le 29 octobre
dernier jean claude blanc le directeur
général délégué du paris saint germain a
confirmé que le campus qui verra le jour
à poissy sera livré pour 2022 ses 74
hectares de terrain une quinzaine de
terrains de football un dojo ou encore
un terrain de handball qui composeront
le futur centre d'entraînement situé à
25 minutes du parc des princes un nom de
rugby maintenant avec nos invités en
plateau lionel garrigues cyril mûriers
etienne nous reçoit les trois jours l'or
est respectivement le coprésident
l'entraîneur et troisième ligne de
l'union rugby s'en tient pas d or jusque
là alors on va parler ensemble des
premiers mois de la toute nouvelle
équipe senior me prononce avec un mot à
propos du dernier match de l'équipe vous
avez joué dimanche la toute jeune équipe
poursuit sa division sa saison en
division honneur alors pour cette
cinquième journée les rugbymans remporté
leur match 26 à 16
une équipe qui n'a pas facilité le jeu
des hymnes ont écouté le capitaine s'est
mérité on sait qu'on a deux essais de
part et d'autre
c'est mérité je pense que sur le sur le
jeu on mérite en tout cas derrière sur
les phases même devant dans le combat
sur la première mi temps mais on a su
mettre de l'avant c'est donc on a pris
la position du match très vite en
permutant mais en deuxième mi-temps on
pousse si on résume 15 mi temps ils
mériteraient de prendre le le prendre
dessus soit deuxième mi temps c'est le
mûrier l'entraîneur est ce que les
propos sont confirmés
ouais sont veuves sont même aujourd'hui
je pense que non pas dire qu'on était
très brillant hier à nous de savoir
pourquoi il avait des mots très durs
avant ça il s'est un peu repris en
reprenant les plus tôt la paix à la
première période mais c'est vrai qui
sait que pas très bon rabat 3 semaines
sans jouer peut-être beaucoup d'envié on
n'a pas su dès qu'on a marqué très
rapidement après on s'est vite agacé je
n'arrivais pas se faire de passard soit
il joue avec la limited ou des moufles
on sait pas encore où trouver des
solutions cette semaine et mai mais
globalement qu'on voit les instincts
on va confier un ace 10 au score c'est
nous qui avons fait le plus gros score
on joue mal mais on gagne donc c'est le
principal une belle réussite au pied les
pénalités ce soir c'est tout à fait et
yann moreau en tant que joueur l'équipe
elle est récente encore est-ce qu'il ya
encore des marques a trouvé bien seul on
sait de go qui annonce rejoint donc
forcément n'est pas on n'est pas encore
en parfaite symbiose etc
mais ça va venir à forcer à force à
faire ça va venir mais voilà on avait
trois semaines de trop il ya peut-être
fait un petit recul en arrière là dessus
mais on a assez confiant à ce sujet
comme des joueurs de qualité donc ça
devrait faire en septembre le capitaine
confié à notre micro que il espérait que
les joueurs trouvent vite leurs marques
les marques sont trouvés est ce que
c'est la confiance et l'écoutent qui est
pas encore très présentes entre vous la
confiance ça vient avec du temps on n'a
peut-être pas encore s est temps pour
avoir vraiment de la confiance mais le
savon ça se trouvait que ce soit sur le
terrain ou en dehors du terrain ça
commence à la mayonnaise commence à
prendre
alors cette mayonnaise doit se trouver
parce que justement on le disait un
petit peu tout à l'heure il ya eu une
fusion votre équipe lui verser vient du
sky rugby montigny-le-bretonneux pour
les équipes seniors cadets de garrigue
vous êtes donc le président le co
président de l'ufc
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé cette
décision de fusionner les deux équipes
où nous sommes deux clubs qui nous
ressemblons depuis longtemps je vais
presque pratiquement au même niveau
depuis longtemps on a
notre mêmes pratiques familiales de
jouer le rugby avec une école de rugby
avec des cadets des juniors et la
difficulté venait pour un club méritant
comme la smb rugby de ne pas disposer de
suffisamment d'effectifs pour justement
puisque en promotion d'honneur on en a
l'obligation d'afficher une équipe
première et l'équipe réserve est là
l'effet d'aubaine
il a consisté est effectivement nous
rassembler a constitué un groupe de
seniors ii d'environ 70 joueurs voilà on
en a moins pendant les vacances aussi le
fait que la préparation a peut être nui
à un résultat du match de diers mais en
tout cas c'est ça c'est cet effet
d'aubaine qu'il fallait mettre en place
pour les deux clubs d'ailleurs un parce
que en promotion d'honneur
effectivement montini bénéficient de la
possibilité de jouer en allant vers nous
mêmes en honneur nous étions en
difficulté en termes d'effectifs
et justement à ce que pour monty né il a
fallu élever un peu le niveau est ce que
la découverte de l'eau nara était plus
compliqué ou sky rugby a transmis ce
qu'ils avaient déjà sur leur saison
précédente
je pense que la différence de niveau
était pas incroyable entre les deux
divisions peut-être physiquement je vous
ils sont passés les équipes en face en
première ne sont pas non plus six
meilleurs que ça donc voilà on a réussi
à élever notre niveau je suis allé pour
entrer dans l'europe puis martin et
aussi avec une belle saison 14 victoires
5 défaites là pour cette nouvelle saison
vous êtes à cinq journées 3 victoires 2
défaites j'imagine que c'est un bon
début pour vous ça débuts satisfaisants
mais
on va essayer de mettre le curseur
termes de rigueur et l'exigence un peu
plus puisque les joueurs nous ont
démontré qu'ils étaient capables de
d'être de gagner contre des grosses
équipes
je pense par exemple à monter sans qui
définirent premier cette année
donc nous donnent des signaux qu'ils ont
des capacités donc on va les suivre et
on va essayer d angela est alors de but
final le maintien déjà j'imagine et
pourquoi pas du zoo mayonnaise et c'est
vrai que là on n'est pas un club sans
ambition au delà
mais l'ambition de cette saison c'est
effectivement que que ce soit au niveau
dirigeants au niveau des joueurs
cette mayonnaise prenne moi ça me plaît
bien le côté culinaire me convient bien
voilà l'ambition c'est vraiment que ce
serait une année de transition on n'est
pas à l'abri d'une très bonne surprise
puisque nous sommes aujourd'hui
quatrième ou cinquième au classement
avec cinq points de différence avec les
premiers qui sont tous à 19 points nous
on est à 14 points si je me trompe pas
voilà j'aimerai bien j'ai en moi la fois
de disputer des phases des phases du
championnat de france franchement ce
serait une belle récompense pour le
groupe pour le pointer plaît pourquoi
pas attirer des plus jeunes ah oui oui
on remercie de souligner cet effort que
nous faisons sur la formation
effectivement puisqu'on parle j'en parle
souvent des seniors on parle de nos
cadets juniors puisque la fusion s'est
faite sur ces trois catégories
principalement mais c'est vrai que
l'école de rugby on a pris un petit peu
de on a pris le temps de d'y arriver je
sais pas combien de temps il faudra
encore pour que nos écoles de rugby qui
sont situés sur trois pôles distinctes
elancourt guyancourt et montigny
fusionnent un jour mais on y arrivera
je prends même pas des féminines mais
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
dit et ce qui nous tient également à
coeur mais voilà à cette époque où le
rugby quand même du mal à avoir un
nombre de licenciés suffisant puisque le
rugby national
peut-être inquiète enfin ce qu'on voit à
la télévision ne favorisent pas là
l'envy peut-être de pratiquer le rugby
bien que des fois et très très beau
match à voir sans aucune violence
selon lui c'est pas la violence tout
contrat et je voulais souligner est
simplement cette cette décision que nous
avions prise de mettre la licence à 50
euros pour tous nouveaux licenciés en
école de rugby et qui nous a fait venir
beaucoup de beaucoup de monde parce
qu'eux aussi ils c'est aussi un sujet
économique ça fait quelque chose de deux
gratuits que de prendre une licence et
50 euros la licence pour toute l'année
on sait pas c'est pas quelque chose de
brader parce que nous avons des
éducateurs bien formés nous avons
d'éducateurs qui sont qui s'en voit là
quelques informations qui sont diplômés
bafa en forme et plus pour par ce décès
de joie on est un tri par le temps en
tout cas merci à trois lettres revenait
sur notre plateau alors pour le prochain
match de luis action vous souhaite un
bon match et on va pas patienter
longtemps
c'est dimanche prochain le 19 ans le 10
novembre et vous êtes face au club de
melun
on continue ce 7,8 sport avec du basket
en nationale 3 trappe réussi son match 2
6e journée de championnat face à
barjouville les trappistes remportent
leur match sur le score de 84 à 59 et la
prochaine rencontre est programmée le 9
novembre à domicile face aux jets ses
hobbies aurel du côté des féminines la
6e journée s'est conclue par une défaite
pour le chesnay-versailles basket opposé
à franconville
l'équipe s'est inclinée 63 68 c'est leur
deuxième défaite de la saison l'équipe
avec débuté avec quatre victoires
malgré les vacances de la toussaint les
gens feria les participants étaient
présents pour la course royal est la
députée à versailles pour s'achever à
fontenay le fleury manon par aldo a
suivi cette septième édition
les coureurs étaient au rendez vous le
départ de la course royal s'est faite à
10h à la pièce d'eau des suisses du
château de versailles pour deux parcours
10 et 20 km 722 participants se sont
élancés pour la 7e édition de la course
royal il ya des passages un peu de dans
la campagne
un petit passage un peu boisée là et
c'est ce que je recherche
ça s'est bien passé c'est une cause qui
est plutôt dur c'est bapela
il ya des chemins des côtes c'est donc
faut savoir gérer jeu c'était assez
boueux donc ça glisse est un peu
compliquée dans les champs les
participants se sont confrontés aux
conditions météorologiques la pluie
était au rendez vous pour cette septième
édition de la course royal comme on dit
dans le jargon des commandes etc ans
agressé le terrain et quelques petites
chutes mais sans aucun sens aucun danger
corps et âmes bien compris l'intérêt un
petit peu gras parce qu'ils sont en
train à semis a trahi des enfants en
situation de handicap participent
également à cette course à bord de trois
ou elle est en fauteuil tout terrain
accompagnés des coureurs des dunes de
l'espoir et de franchissant le mur
présent depuis trois ans ils ont
effectué le parcours des 10 km ça s'est
très bien passé
et puis à son sac ans page a eu l'invité
viable parce que ce que c'est ma
meilleure amie ça fait dix ans que
j'avais beaucoup effectivement c'était
dix ans et j'ai retrouvé des sensations
que j'ai connu il ya dix ans l'heure des
résultats a sonné la grande gagnante des
10 km s'appelle l'uci pour sa première
participation à la course
royal elle est arrivée en première place
avec un temps de 42 minutes et 47
secondes
une huitième édition de la course royal
est espérée avec encore plus de coureurs
l'année prochaine nous avions reçues sur
tv 78 romy fournée 28 ans originaire de
carrières sous poissy a réussi à
terminer le raid des amazones au vietnam
elle était aux côtés de sa soeur
sandrine alors la 20e édition de cette
compétition entièrement féminine était
organisée à la mi octobre sur cinq jours
avec au programme du canoë du tir à
l'arc du vtt du trail ou encore de la
run and bike leur équipe baptisé five to
gather a terminé 57e sur 94 équipes
les deux soeurs nous ont justement
envoyer une vidéo depuis l'asie pour
débriefer leurs expériences et surtout
leurs sentiments à l'arrivée regarder
l'arrivée
indisponible mais comme les guerrières
qui ont fini leur l'ambassade
et puis surtout course avec cette
dernière arrivée la dernière épreuve à
la fin du raid ben à la fin de tous ces
mois de préparation l'aboutissement un
nouveau club de boxe a ouvert vpx the
box accueille les habitants des clés
sous bois et de vie pr 80,2 adhérents
vient de s'entraîner la boxe est un
sport physique que notre journaliste
manon varaldo a testé pour vous mathilde
et demi pour les images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me trouve actuellement au complexe
sportif alain mimoun pour tester pour
vous en cours de boxe proposées par
l'association
vpi boxe allez c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est parti pour l'échauffement chevy
bras montées de genoux avant de passer
au cardio sous l'oeil avisé du coach
larry
[Musique]
place ensuite aux exercices montré par
les coaches qu'il faut ensuite enchaîné
toutes les 30 secondes
l'enchaînement est intensif le cardio
est très sollicité le représentant en
même temps et en septembre le club de
boxe anglaise vpx début de sa première
saison les clés siens et villepreux
chiens adultes débutants ou confirmés
sont accueillis on a pu voir quelques
femmes s'entraîner vous en avez beaucoup
on a 26 % de féminines
donc c'est à peu près la moyenne au
niveau au niveau de la boxe au niveau
national on est à peu près sûr ces
pourcentages
quel est l'objectif de ces sports
l'objectif de la boxe c'est avant tout
un dépassement de soi je pense qu'on
n'arrive jamais par hasard dans une
salle de boxe
soit on a quelqu'un dans la famille qui
a déjà boxé soit on a une envie de se
dépenser de se dépasser de dépasser de
repousser ses limites et c'est un très
bon score pour ça 82 adhérents viennent
s'entraîner chez vp xbox au début c'est
physique
mais évidemment tu t'améliores et après
les séances de tests physiques mais tu
t'améliores du coup tu as moins de mal à
aller finir et une fois qu'elles sont
finis tes c'est bien tu es content
d'avoir fini c'est pas un bon complément
pour se défouler à la fin de chaque
semaine en fait parce que quand on est
étudiant par exemple comme moi et qu'on
travaille aussi à côté la boxe est un
bon moyen de souffler cet entraînement
permet de revoir la technique que les
adhérents peuvent ensuite mettre en
application par binôme notamment la
position
il faut imaginer qu'une corde passe
entre vos jambes ce qui permet d'avoir
les quillous lary le coach et mon binôme
du jour ils me montrent plusieurs
enchaînements et ça demande beaucoup de
coordination dans le dos
hop il est important de bien maintenir
sa garde sinon quelques coups peuvent
arriver avec larry place ensuite aux
esquives et je peux vous dire que ça
fait beaucoup travailler les jambes
l'homme après quelques fois j'ai réussi
un enchaînement avec l'art il est
composé des esquives et de crochets
c'est aussi un sport qui demande de la
rigueur
cela dit on peut pas se permettre
certains écarts donc forcément si là
nous on a mal dormi
on a mal manger on le ressent
directement ça triche pas on peut pas
tricher en dhr c'est pas possible
pour adhérer avait px boxe il vous
faudra débourser 260 euros à l'année et
comptait entre 30 et 50 euros pour la
licence la amadou qu'avec moi le futur
champion de boxe il va montrer comment
mettre un bon coup
ouais ouais ouais
à quoi bon
- mâcon
merci beaucoup pour tes conseils je vais
continuer de m'entraîner comme vous
l'avez vu un entraînement intensif mais
j'ai eu des bons conseils de mon coach
paris à plus tard
[Musique]
et on continue de parler de boxe marvin
petit est de retour sur les rings
le boxeur de la team farrugia elancourt
va participer à un combat le 9 novembre
à la baule un rendez vous pour se
préparer en vue d'un championnat
d'europe ou encore un championnat du
monde
le sportif de 28 ans va affronter les
amours salées à ce jour marvin petit
alias marvelous contre 24 victoires en
27 combats dont 12 par ko et on les
écoute mais j'appréhende un combat
commun de quoi je suis pressé de montres
sonneries et en découdre j'espère que sa
tête avait bien prête parce que habitue
les coups je lui met je crois qu'il va
être la boxe on continue un instant avec
marvin de petits le boxeur élan courtois
s'est prêtée à notre désormais
traditionnel jeu des trois questions
[Musique]
j'ai commencé tout jeune déjà j'ai
commencé parce que
monté en année la boxe j'étais quelqu'un
que
les présages battait souvent il m'a dit
je vais d'inscrire la boxe et je ne sert
qu'à ça rigole je dis bon hockey et il
m'a bien la boxe c'est vrai j'ai
commencé à aimer j'ai aimé j'ai un
combat qui aura le plus marqué c'est le
combat de yvan mendy et je redirai sur
toutes les vidéos
parce que quand je rentrais j'ai bon
j'étais pas sérieux je lui ai pris à la
légère ce combat
j'étais pas entraîner du tout une
semelle rouge est en boîte mais mon
entraîneur antoine farrugia qui m'avait
dit
dans les vestiaires tu vas perdre jours
de combats moi je disais non non
et malheureusement j'ai perdu deux
touches mais aussi malheureusement j'ai
en fait j'avais baissé les mains ma
fille jo objectif c'est de
de reflation paddock ou un champagne
marne propose la plus importante c'est
de recherche pas d'europe pour l'année
2020 et ce week-end c'est aussi la
première manche de la coupe d'hiver le
sixième grand prix de vélizy rassemblera
ce dimanche 10 novembre
cent soixante dix cyclistes alors pour
en parler avec nous l'organisateur
bonjour jean michel richefort bonjour
donc 170 coureurs mais qui viennent de
toute la france
oui 170 participants pour ce sixième
grand prix de vélizy donc c'est vraiment
un succès on est on est très content et
on va accueillir effectivement des
pistards en provenance de tous les
comités régionaux avec de jeunes espoirs
et puis des talents confirmés
et puis un beau programme vous avez
trois épreuves le scratch le caine et
l'oignon laissé en plus des épreuves un
peu spectaculaire oui mais toutes les
épreuves sur piste sont spectaculaires
bien sûr nous avons de la vitesse du
kérygme et là nous avons nous nous
aurons des des jeunes du pôle france
donc et les espoirs pour 2024
on espère et puis des omniums des
omniums dans toutes les catégories avec
du scratch de l'élimination de la course
aux points et de jeunes talents dont des
des jeunes de saint quentin en yvelines
et je pense tout particulièrement et à
roanne l'ouvrier qui était champion de
france celio l'ère du vélo club de
montigny le bretonneux paul penhoët qui
va passer professionnel donc dans le
dans la formation
groupama et vj et tout cela avec un
invité d'honneur
quentin lafargue quentin lafargue qui a
débuté d'ailleurs au premier grand prix
de vélizy et aujourd'hui il est champion
du monde du kilomètre et il sera là
toute la journée donc pour veiller sur
les gentils qu'on fait voilà les bien
sûr bien sûr pour distiller des conseils
aux plus jeunes est ce que vous l'avez
dit on va le pôle france chez des petits
jeunes parce que le principe c'est de
voir toutes les catégories et on m'a
même jusqu'au master oui bien sûr des
minimes des cadets des juniors d élite
1re 2e catégorie et puis des masters et
parmi les masters donc
trois récents champions du monde masters
et
qui ont participé aux championnats du
monde à manchester là il ya une dizaine
de jours yann dujarrier sébastien terry
et arnaud du blé et ils seront
confrontés donc aux jeunes du pôle
france donc là ce sera forcément
spectaculaire et en vitesse et en kering
alors c'est la première manche de la
coupe d'hiver ce qu'elle la place de
cette compétition dans un calendrier
pour ceux qui vont s'y présenter et bien
c'est très important parce que la piste
c'est une discipline bien sûr hivernale
même si les championnats de france ont
lieu en été mais c'est une discipline
très complémentaire de la route
et cette première manche donc démarre la
saison hivernale avec une deuxième
manche en décembre début décembre
le 1er décembre la troisième manche
début janvier et avec une finale fin
janvier voilà donc ça permet donc de
faire vivre ce vélodrome l'hiver et sans
oublier le samedi 16 novembre le gala
des stars donc où là seront opposées des
professionnels de la route aux élites 2
de la piste on a donné beaucoup de noms
masculins
mais la particularité de ce week-end
mais aussi de nombreuses féminines voilà
alors ça c'est une particularité et
nous en sommes fiers parce que
tante en minimes cadettes qu'en juniors
seniors donc les courses font le plat et
avec un plateau exceptionnel en juniors
et en seniors avec deux championnes de
france est une toute jeune championne du
monde juniors donc marie divine kouam
qui a été championne du monde du 500
mètres là cet été donc ça aussi c'est
vraiment une grande satisfaction que de
voir toutes ces féminines et c'est un
peu la suite du plan de féminisation
qu'a mis en place la fédération
française de cyclisme
et voilà ça commence à porter ses fruits
et là nous en sommes très satisfaits et
en quelques mots ce qu'on nous sommes un
peu pressés par le temps ce 6ème journée
nous avions dû rendre en hommage à une
personne du club de vélizy un petit mot
oui ce sera le souvenir michel barraud
c'est un passionné de deux pistes et
puis surtout un grand dirigeant de
l'équipe cycliste de vélizy qui nous a
quitté cet été et donc ce sixième grand
prix donc sera placé sous le souvenir
michel barraud donc on attend bien aux
cultures de très nombreux spectateurs à
partir de 10h du matin et jusqu'à 18
heures au dimanche il aura de quoi
découvrir toutes ses formidables
l'épreuve de cyclisme merci 1 jean
michel richefort vous rappelle juste le
sixième grand prix de vélizy débute à
10h comme l'avait dit ce dimanche 10
novembre
on termine ce tour de l'actualité
sportive avec quelques rendez vous du
football et la première division de
district ce dimanche 10 novembre à 15h
voisins le bretonneux reçoit ou au parc
des sports du grand-pré lévis chinois
sont à l'heure actuelle 3e du
championnat avec trois points d'avancé
sur wii qui est 8e et si vous voulez lui
si les soutenir l'entrée est libre
en rugby après une très belle victoire
contre sarcelles en fédérale 2 plaisir
8e du championnat tentera de remporter
son duel contre le paris université club
une équipe qu'il est devant une petite
place au classement est la rencontre est
programmée ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade robert barran de plaisir et un
dernier rendez vous du football
versailles connaît son adversaire depuis
le 29 octobre en coupe de france
l'équipe partira direction la réunion
pour le 7e tour de la compétition
elle affrontera sainte marienne club de
régionale 1 lors du 6e tour les
versaillais avait remporté leur match à
viry-châtillon au terme d'une séance de
tirs au but
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous retrouvez mary ellen
d'euros la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro 10 il a passé une bonne
semaine sportive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]